bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24
consacré à la reine Elizabeth II les
médecins de la souveraine se disent
préoccupés par son état de santé c'est
ce qu'a annoncé le palais de Buckingham
vous voyez ces images à Londres la reine
Elizabeth II doit rester sous
surveillance médicale sa famille est à
son chevet à Balmoral dans son château
en école le prince Harry et sa femme
Mégane sont également en route vers
l'école le Royaume-Uni et littéralement
suspendu à l'état de santé de ça à
souveraine on va en parler dans ce débat
assez longuement avec mes invités j'ai
le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés Philippe
Taure le notre chroniqueur international
sur France 24 bonsoir Philippe merci
d'être avec nous Jérémy stop bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous directeur adjoint
de la rédaction de Causeur vous êtes
également président de l'association des
conservateurs britanniques de Paris
bienvenue à vous nous avons Hervé
amauric à Londres un autre correspondant
qui va être avec nous tout au long de
cette émission rebonsoir Hervé et puis
Kevin Guyot qui est avec nous historien
fondateur du site la monarchie
britannique.com bonsoir à vous et merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir nous
avons aussi par Skype de Londres Agnès
Poirier journaliste correspondant de
L'Express à Londres bonsoir à vous Agnès
Poirier bienvenue également bonsoir
ça a été annoncé il y a à peu près deux
heures les médecins donc ils se disent
préoccupés par la santé de la reine
Elizabeth II depuis bien sûr une foule
commence à se rassembler devant
Buckingham Palace on va écouter d'abord
quelques réactions
elle est la reine depuis que je suis en
vie depuis que mes parents sont en vie
donc elle est vraiment une partie très
très importante de la société vous savez
ça va être terrible si elle meurt
il y a deux jours elle était avec la
nouvelle Première ministre et maintenant
d'un coup tout le monde s'inquiète pour
elle c'est triste mais god save the
queen
direction tout de suite donc un jeudi à
notre correspondant à Hervé la foule sa
masse un peu plus chaque minute
j'imagine
absolument on les voit de plus en plus
désormais il dépasse on voit les gens
des deux côtés du monument tout à
l'heure il y avait un seul côté du
monument on voyait une une marée de
parapluie mais maintenant il pleut moins
et effectivement il y a des gens un peu
partout ce qui on peut s'attendre à ce
que cette place est tout le mal ici qui
descend jusqu'au presque jusqu'au au
Parlement là-bas soit noir ne monte
bientôt c'était le cas à l'époque du
moment du Jubilé de la célébration des
70 ans de règne d'Elizabeth II lorsque
la population est venue dire adieu aux
monarque dans Elizabeth II dans son rôle
officiel au balcon de Buckingham Palace
toute sa famille était rassemblée comme
elle l'est aujourd'hui ses enfants ses
petits-enfants parmi eux bien sûr
plusieurs
héritiers de la couronne le prince
Charles son fils William et même les
petits enfants qui étaient les enfants
de William qui était là derrière elle et
qui ont assisté aux cérémonies donc
c'était un moment un moment qui était en
de symboles des moments symboliques de
son règne effectivement les gens qui
sont ici ce soir savent que bientôt ils
pourront rendre hommage à la reine et
dire en adieu à la reine la personne la
femme effectivement la fin de de
long règne s'approche tout le monde ici
autour de nous tous les Britanniques ou
presque tous non connu que Elizabeth II
comme renne comme symbole de l'unité de
ce pays malgré toutes les divisions
malgré le brexit qui a frauuré la
société malgré
les divisions politiques lors de
l'annonce de listrus qui a formé un
gouvernement très à droite évidemment
côté travailliste toute une partie de la
population
rejette une partie de de cette pensée
politique mais à partir de cet
après-midi le Britannique seront unis on
ne parle plus du plan énergétique de
listrot sont ne s'inquiète presque plus
de comment on va payer ses factures de
gaz ou d'électricité effectivement les
gens sont inquiets et pense à la fin de
des dernières heures au dernier jour de
leur souverain
Philippe Philipp Plein vous êtes franco
britannique lorsque les médecins disent
qu'ils sont inquiets préoccupés par
l'état de santé de la reine qu'est-ce
que ça signifie quelle sera la prochaine
communication à Buckingham Palace ça
c'est toute la question alors pour
mettre quelque chose dans l'ordre les
communiquer sur la santé de la reine
sont extrêmement rare la dernière fois
on a eu deux ou trois mais mais c'est
quand même excessivement rare on a eu
une communauté avec pour dire qu'elle a
eu le covid et on a une communiqué pour
dire qu'elle avait dit des problèmes de
mobilité donc c'est en moins présente
pour pour les festivités du jubilé mais
on n'a pas accès
aux informations de santé de la reine ça
fait partie de la domaine privée en
Grande-Bretagne et donc on peut pas se
poser la question comment on va la reine
et avoir la réponse donc on est
assujetté assujetti à la à la merci de
bac impalas qui va nous distiller des
informations au fur et à mesure du
moment ils pensent eux que c'est propice
pour qu'on sache comment avoir la reine
on a eu cette annonce tout à l'heure
vers 13h30 heure de Paris nous indiquons
que la reine a été mal en point
on n'attend pas d'autres nouvelles de la
part de ces médecins ni de la part de
bac impalas qui va nous informer de ce
qui va se passer alors que vu
l'inquiétude grandissante la foule qui
commence à se masser devant backing
Palace et aussi à balmor et toutes les
chaînes d'informations
partout dans le monde qui font du
non-stop sur la haine je pense que la
pression monte pour que les médecins
nous donnent quelques informations sur
la santé normalement je pense que mon
avis c'est que l'annonce qui était fait
cet après-midi
et peut-être une façon de préparer le
peuple britannique à une annonce plus
grave pour ne pas les faire les choquer
avec une annonce inattendue sur le décès
de la mort du Mona de la monarque donc
je pense que c'est un premier pas pour
préparer l'opinion publique à une
annonce peut-être plus grave plus tard
se transforme pas trop choqué le moment
où cette annonce soit posté juste pour
information comment on va la prendre si
la reine est décédée c'est toujours la
même manière il y aura une annonce qu'il
soit affichée devant bacon Palace je
pense que nous saura avant mais
officiellement c'est un annonce qui
afficher devant le palace sur les
grilles tout petit annonce qui va
exactement comme pour son père jour je
suis en 1952
donc il devrait y avoir une annonce
écrite si effectivement on doit
apprendre ce soir ou dans les jours qui
viennent le décès de la reine oui tout à
fait tout à fait ce sera fait selon les
en bonne et due forme selon la tradition
et tout cela est extrêmement important
en même temps
l'inquiétude est tellement grande en ce
moment que si
c'était exagéré quelqu'un nous aurait
dit calmez-vous donc le fait que cela
monte sans
[Musique]
de quoi à s'inquiéter donc on a eu cette
photo qui était un effort je pense pour
calmer l'esprit le public
l'opinion publique pour dire bah voilà
la reine elle est debout elle a sa canne
mais c'est à la main de l'histoire le
problème c'est que quand on voit cette
photo de la reine on la voit très
affaiblie très intégrée elle a une
grosse tache sur la main droite ce qui
veut dire qu'elle a peut-être subi des
perfusions mais c'est une femme
visiblement qui est très frêle donc
alors que c'était une photo
publiée pour rassurer les gens je pense
que ça inquiétait peut-être plus que ça
n'a rassuré vous êtes d'accord avec
cette photo a plutôt inquiéter les gens
et on est en train de préparer ce que
disait j'ai jamais eu stop on est en
train de préparer les Britanniques et
d'ailleurs le monde entier au décès de
la reine c'est ce qui se passe en ce
moment
oui c'est une évidence et puis il faut
toujours lire entre les lignes parce que
en fait ça a commencé quand on regarde
les parlementaires sur la Chaîne
Parlementaire ce qui était mon cas
aujourd'hui
et que tout d'un coup il y a eu cette
fébrilité alors d'abord l'histoire on
apprend par un des députés présents à la
Chambre des communes et Chris Brown
député de travailler c'était même
Twitter à ce moment-là en disant quelque
chose d'inhabituel est en train de se
passer il y a un briefing
urgent donc les stress part ensuite
aller suivie de Kia Starman on a pu voir
d'ailleurs des petits mots échangés sur
les bancs entre les députés l'atmosphère
était assez fébrile il continuait comme
ça à prendre la parole à tour de rôle
pour la question du jour mais enfin pour
les questions à l'ordre du jour pardon
et donc déjà la fébrilité commencée et
puis ensuite on a eu ce communiqué de
bucking camp Palace mais il faut
vraiment s'il y a beaucoup de retenue et
donc du coup c'est inquiétant parce que
comme la rappeler Philippe on ne
Buckingham Palace ne parle pas de la
santé de la reine à moins qu'il y ait
quelque chose de majeur et donc oui il y
a une préparation ne même que à 14h tout
d'un coup on a vu les présentateurs de
la BBC d'abord habillé en bleu marine et
maintenant noir
savent-ils quelque chose que nous ne
savons pas encore c'est possible donc
même si à la seconde de la mort de la
souveraine tout depuis des années tout
il y a un protocole on sait exactement
ce que ce qui va se passer le moment
n'est pas encore arrivé du moins
officiellement et voilà les Britanniques
maintenant savent que c'est une question
probablement d'heure
Kevin Guyot puisque vous êtes
l'historien de ce plateau c'est une
question d'heure est-ce que tout vous
semble je dirais vous qui êtes
l'historien tout vous semble aller dans
ce sens là cette préparation au décès de
la reine quoi on dirait plutôt dans les
heures qui viennent dans les jours qui
viennent
[Musique]
on pense surtout aux mots préoccupation
ce mot a été utilisé quelques fois par
le passé surtout lorsqu'on pense ou par
un suivi la seule fois où ils ont
utilisé ce mot c'est vraiment lorsqu'il
était à la fin de sa vie et lorsqu'on
l'État était le plus préoccupant
justement donc de savoir qu'ils
utilisent ce mot c'est déjà pensé que la
reine sur le point de décéder et que les
jours vont bien tout arriver et comme ce
enfin ce jour va bien tout arriver et
par rapport aux effets de mon passé
c'est vraiment comme ça que ça s'est
déroulé c'est vraiment comme ça qu'ils
auraient préparer les Britanniques dans
le sens où comme disait Philippe pour le
roi George VI à sa mort on a vraiment
suivi le protocole à l'aller comme on va
faire aujourd'hui sauf qu'aujourd'hui on
va ajouter une pointe de modernité je
vous interrompre pardon pardonnez-moi
parce qu'on a un vrai problème de son
avec vous on va essayer de le régler ce
problème de son en attendant on va
revenir un petit peu justement sur ce
parcours de la Reine qui a accédé au
trône en 1952 d'ailleurs en 199 ça a
marqué un tournant dans la monarchie
britannique on dit justement que et bien
il a commencé à y avoir des réformes
alors est-ce que cette monarchie
britannique s'est adaptée c'est
transformé on voit tout de suite cela en
images avec Caroline Grandjean et Andrea
[Musique]
son image a marqué l'histoire Elisabeth
II reine de l'ère postmod moderne et de
ses médias sous le feu des projecteurs
elle connaît les débuts de la télévision
les tableaux hits font aussi l'opinion
publique en étalant la vie des
célébrités en 1992 un incendie ravage le
château de Windsor c'est alors au
contribuable que revient la facture des
réparations de la demeure préférée de la
reine
pour éviter au Britannique de payer les
travaux de leur poche l'année suivante
la reine a une idée ouvrir le palais de
Buckingham au public une première et un
succès Windsor peut renaître de ses
centres grâce à la vente de billets et
produit dérivés
la décennie 90 a mis à rude épreuve
l'image de la souveraine et de la
monarchie le divorce de Diana et Charles
le prince héritier donne lieu à un
véritable tapage médiatique rumeur de
tromperie scandale les moindres faits et
gestes de l'ancien couple sont scrutés
un déchaînement des paparazzis qui prend
des allures de harcèlement pour Diana
la princesse Diana qui avait conquis le
cœur du public reste dans les bonnes
grâces du peuple britannique en 1997 le
silence de la reine après la mort de
Lady Di est assourdissant
un quart des Britanniques souhaite alors
l'abolition de la monarchie véritable
tournant dans l'histoire la famille
royale doit revoir son image et c'est un
mariage qui lui en donne l'occasion en
2011 où il y a le petit-fils de la reine
Elizabeth épouse Kate Middleton une
roturière
c'est l'avènement d'une nouvelle
génération princière
qui se départit de la tradition
[Applaudissements]
c'était si beau elle était vraiment
magnifique tout était somptueux toute la
famille royale s'était extraordinaire
7 ans après c'est au tour du cadet de se
marier Harry épouse Meghan Markle une
actrice afro-américaine divorcée et
offre ainsi un compte de tous les
possibles aux médias les deux couples
royaux rivalisent l'initiatives voyagent
et bénévoles soignent les relations
publiques de la famille royale opération
communication
la souveraine dévoile son côté espiègle
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture des Jeux
Olympiques de Londres en 2012 elle
apparaît dans une vidéo aux côtés de
Daniel Craig dans le rôle de James Bond
des milliards de téléspectateurs
assistant direct à une mise en scène
stupéfiante avant de la voir gagner la
tribune royale
les Windsor adoptent désormais de
nouveaux codes et surf sur les réseaux
sociaux une façon de rendre accessible
le Fast et les ordres de la royauté
mieux maîtriser la communication de la
Couronne a bien évolué Elizabeth II a
même un compte Instagram
direction tout de suite Buckingham
Palace justement on retrouve encore
Hervé Hervé Amoric vous êtes toujours
avec nous on est t-on devant Buckingham
Palace la foule continue à venir
et je dois me retourner et je dois dire
qu'à chaque fois que je me retourne il y
a beaucoup plus de gens désormais ça
arrive presque jusqu'à nous il y a un
périmètre de sécurité ici pour les
chaînes de télévision du monde entier
qui sont à côté de moi justement pour
parce qu'il y a de plus en plus de gens
et sur le mal et c'est on voit des une
foule de gens qui qui s'approchent alors
effectivement maintenant les gens ont
fini de travailler sans doute et de plus
en plus de gens s'approchent ici et ont
appris que bien sûr il y a des
inquiétudes à travers le pays ils ont
entendu d'abord les stress et ensuite
tous les chefs de parties parler de leur
inquiétude ils ont sans doute vu la BBC
en
sur toutes les chaînes la chaîne de news
avec leur présentateur comme disait tout
à l'heure
l'un des invités sur le plateau en
habitant et cela en dit très long la
dernière fois que qu'on a vu les
préparent tout à fait la dernière fois
que qu'on a vu des présentateurs de la
BBC avec une cravate noire c'était pour
la le décès du prince Philippe il y a un
an on peut plus d'un an maintenant et on
sait très bien que cela a beaucoup
perturbé la reine la perte de son époux
a été un choc monumental et on s'attend
effectivement à ce que depuis ce
moment-là l'état de santé de la reine a
cessé de diminuer jusqu'à sa mobilité
perdue au moment du jubilé ici où elle
n'a pas pu être dans le carrosse royale
être au cœur de ces cérémonies pour les
70 ans de de son règne de la célébration
de son règne et c'était l'adieu officiel
de la reine sans doute un adieu touchant
qui a duré plusieurs jours et la
population tout entière a pu dire au
revoir au monarque à ce moment-là et
bien évidemment tous ceux qui qui
désormais ont peuvent venir ici bon sans
doute ça m'assait comme c'est le cas
c'est la tradition c'était la tradition
pour la mort de Diana la tradition pour
la mort de Philippe et maintenant
évidemment tout le monde attend une
annonce officielle qui sera sans doute
une annonce du décès de la reine ça vous
étonne pas cette foule qui s'amasse peu
à peu devant Buckingham Palace et la
tradition elle est très populaire la
reine Elizabeth II elle est très
populaire elle a traversé des périodes
de où elle avait moins la côte mais
aujourd'hui elle est très populaire et
comment on explique cette popularité
alors que ça fait 70 ans qu'elle est
reine mais justement c'est la constance
c'est la constance elle incarne une
sorte de comment on dit en français une
sorte
britannique qui plaît beaucoup aux gens
surtout
en sachant que nous avons renverser déjà
des des
temps un peu difficiles et qu'on va en
traverser de nouveau c'est vraiment cet
exemple là qui plaît aux gens et les
gens sont attachés à la reine parce
qu'elle incarne une sorte d'idéal
spécifiquement britannique peut-être
mais un idéal Elisabeth II un 47 idéal
et pourquoi et bien parce que elle a
trouvé la juste mesure entre le
stoïcisme et l'empathie et ça ce point
d'équilibre est très rare très rare
pratiquement inconnu chez les politiques
pas souvent le cas chez les rois et les
reines mais elle elle assume le trouver
est-ce que son successeur s'il y a un
successeur sera le faire je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas elle
elle a le secret magique le secret
magique Kevin Guyot vous êtes j'espère
que la liaison rétablit avec vous vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
Jérémy stop
de continuité dans le sens où
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment à la reine
que l'on pense lorsqu'on pense justement
à la réelle il y a plusieurs règles en
Europe il y avait dans le monde et
pourtant quand on pense à la reine on
pense à Elisabeth II c'est pas pour rien
c'est parce qu'il est vrai vraiment
partie de notre quotidien et elle fait
partie en fait elle représente le passé
le fait et aussi le présent du
Royaume-Uni de l'histoire européenne et
de l'histoire du monde
vous étiez bien sûr je crois à Londres
lorsque elle a reçu la toute nouvelle
Première ministre qu'elle a officialisé
sa nomination listrot c'était mardi mais
listrot est allé à Balmoral donc en
Écosse on vient d'apprendre qu'elle est
morte me dit Philippe Turl a l'instant
donc en direct sur France 24 on vient
d'apprendre
pour le moment c'est ce que vous dites
Philippe
ça provient pour l'instant c'est selon
les médias Philippe il faut bien faut
bien préciser
qui indique que la reine Elizabeth II
est décédée à l'âge de 90 ans 96 ans
d'après le bacon Palace donc c'est
uniquement un média qu'il annonce à
Philippe Turl soyez juste précis quel
est le média qu'il annonce c'est Sky
News qui cite backing Palace donc la
résidence à la reine devant laquelle
toute cette foule est amassé donc voilà
il faut rester prudent parce que ça
paraît été confirmé par d'autres médias
pour le moment donc voilà
je suis en train justement de regarder
le fil AFP comme on dit les agences de
King and the Queen will Remed pour
l'instant ce qu'on apprend c'est que
pour le moment toute la famille est
toujours à Balmoral
ils viennent c'est officiel à l'instant
c'est ce que vous nous dites pourrier
qui est à Londres c'est officiel donc la
reine est morte à l'âge de 96 ans Agnès
Poirier
c'était en fait cet après-midi
et c'est bien ce que beaucoup d'entre
nous pensions quand nous avons vu cet
après-midi des présentateurs de la BBC
qui était en noir avec ça en noir
uniquement à partir du moment où elle
souverain est mort et certains d'entre
eux étaient très émus et donc on s'est
on s'est tous dit ils savent quelque
chose que nous ne savons pas comme je
vous avais dit
il y a une demi-heure voilà Hervé
vous êtes toujours devant Buckingham
Palace et je l'imagine qu'il doit y
avoir des réactions ce soir on vient
d'apprendre donc la mort de la reine
c'est officielle c'est un communiqué de
Buckingham Palace maintenant qui le dit
oui absolument essayer tout le monde
tous mes collègues tout le monde est
bien sûr une un moment de qui a on
s'attendait bien sûr à ce que à cette
annonce on s'en on s'attendait peut-être
peut-être pas à ce que l'annonce Vienne
aussi vite en attendant derrière moi
vous allez voir maintenant les gens qui
vont s'agglutiner devant Buckingham
Palace et il y a de plus en plus de gens
qui qui viennent ça sera sans doute une
soirée difficile une soirée où les gens
vont venir rendre hommage et puis
maintenant toute toute l'étiquette va te
mettre en place tout ce qui est prévu
pour la séparation
on vous a perdu Hervé Jeremy stop donc
voilà on l'a appris la reine est morte
c'est vrai que c'est presque un choc
pour nous aussi parce que ça fait
plusieurs heures que on l'attendait là
il y a tout un protocole qui va se
mettre en place ou raconter nous déjà
les drapeaux en berne ça ils vont être
en berne à travers le pays toute une
journée qu'est-ce qui va se passer là au
Royaume-Uni et bien il va falloir que
on parle n'est-ce pas des deux corps des
rois le corps matériel le corps
symbolique donc le corps de la reine est
mort en Écosse mais il faut que ce corps
soit transporté
en train jusqu'à Londres avec des arrêts
nombreux sur le chemin
ensuite il y aura une période où le
corps sera exposé et les personnes
pourront
défiler devant et ça ça va durer combien
de temps ou ça va durer je pense 9 jours
c'est un protocole qui est un protocole
ça y est devient donc il prend sa
succession et il devient donc roi
d'Angleterre est automatique
c'est son fils Charles qui devient
automatiquement le roi c'est pourquoi on
dit la reine est morte longue vie au roi
parce que c'est la succession est
immédiat il y a pas de de break entre le
entre et son successeur ça ça prend un
point deuxième point c'est que là toute
une protocole qui va rentrer en jeu à
partir de tout de suite il va y avoir
une période où on va baisser tous les
drapeaux sur les monuments voilà il faut
informer tous les les chefs de
gouvernement le Premier ministre les
chefs d'états du monde les chefs du TAS
d'État du commonwef tout le monde doit
être informé
pour qu'ils puissent prendre les
disposition nécessaire soit pour venir à
Londres pour pour informer les gens qui
sont des plus proches après cela
normalement le prince char doit prendre
la parole
rapidement après le décès de sa mère et
à partir de demain va commencer dix
jours de
préparation pour cette enterrement à
savoir que la reine est en décédée à
balmorro son cercueil transporté à
Londres par le train ou elle sera mis
dans le palais de Westminster c'est le
ciel du gouvernement britannique où il y
aura une période de deuil où le public
va pouvoir passer devant de cette
période de deuil de 10 jours Philippe
pour pour
montrer
le respect et leur remerciements à la
reine ensuite pour le dernier jour le
circuit sur la transporter au palais de
l'abbaye de Westminster qui est juste à
côté du Palais de Westminster pour la
cérémonie des obsèques et ensuite elle
sort enterrée à côté son mari au château
de Windsor Kevin Guyot vous peut-être
réagir justement vous qui êtes
l'historien de ce plateau
oui je suis désolé je suis un petit peu
un petit peu ému de tout ça et j'étais
en train de faire du coup mes
publications pour annoncer la mort de la
réalité tous ceux qui le suivent et
effectivement je suis je suis très ému
je suis très on attendait forcément la
mort de la reine c'est un fait elle a 80
elle avait 96 ans elle était affaiblie
on l'a dit on l'a vu pendant la dernière
photo qu'on a pu voir dès où elle où
elle a donc elle recevait sa nouvelle
Première ministre donc la 15e de son
règne un record donc effectivement
c'était un c'était vraiment un
[Musique]
flambeau qui a pu nous emmener pendant
ces 70 ans et qui nous quitte
aujourd'hui qui qui représentait de
l'histoire comme je disais autant que le
présent parce que c'est une souveraine
qui assume moderniser la monarchie pour
en faire une institution
remarquable et incontournable pour le
Royaume-Uni aujourd'hui personne
quasiment personne aujourd'hui au
Royaume-Uni va contredire le fait que le
Royaume-Uni doit rester une monarchie
même si on ne sait pas on ne savait pas
jusque là si le prince Charles allait
vraiment prendre sa succession même si
certains allaient vrai aller à les poser
la question si un cheval avait vraiment
prendre la succession à la place du
prince William alors que tout esthétique
écrit on savait très bien depuis le
départ ça allait être le prince Charles
parce que c'est écrit dans la
Constitution
Kevin Guillot on a il y a toujours un
petit problème de son avec vous j'ai
l'impression qu'il va disparaître au fur
et à mesure on sent votre votre émotion
on dirait Miss top donc là aujourd'hui
enfin maintenant au moment où on se
parle on peut dire que c'est donc
Charles qui est le roi d'Angleterre
comme on dit en France en tout cas c'est
c'est vrai du Royaume-Uni roi
d'Angleterre et roi d'Écosse et et en
fait pour le moment un roi de d'Irlande
du Nord
oui il était prince qui peut être Galles
maintenant il est il est roi et c'est ça
la continuité dont on parlait Kevin Guy
oui elle est automatique oui tout à fait
tout à fait à moins que dans les jours à
venir il annonce que il décide
d'appliquer mais ça peut probable à mon
avis il a attendu très très longtemps
pour
prendre ce poste en quelque sorte
et on sait qu'il n'attendait que ça
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui il est
différent de la reine dans la mesure où
il a des idées politiques et sociales
qui ne craint pas d'exprimer de temps en
temps
d'une façon qui est qui n'est pas
vraiment dans la tradition établie par
Elisabeth II alors là il y aura un
changement peut-être la plus grande
question c'est est-ce qu'il va se
prendre le modèle de sa mère et change
et complètement ou est-ce qu'il va
essayer de rester un peu lui-même et de
continuer à intervenir à faire des
déclarations par exemple sur l'écologie
ainsi de suite c'est ça la grande
question
on voit cette image voilà vous pouvez
Philippe Turl c'est Buckingham Palace
tout à l'heure qui annonce le décès de
la reine on a eu la même chose en 1952 à
l'eau du décès de jauge 6 donc c'est la
confirmation de la du décès du de la
monarche et donc la succession au prince
Charles tout est très formel parking
Palace c'est c'est l'un des gros
problèmes qui a eu le prince Philippe
quand la reine est arrivée sur l'autre
en 1952 à savoir que y trouvait que
cette maison n'avait pas bougé depuis
des centaines d'années que il fallait
pour passer un message donner le message
à un valet qui allait transporter sur un
plateau en argent à l'autre bout du
palais attendre le message de retour il
m'a dit mais je vais prendre au
téléphone non non c'est pas comme ça que
ça se passe donc c'est très difficile
pour faire bouger les coutumes
centenaires de centenaires de cette
maison et là l'annonce du décès de El 2
est posté sous les grilles comme ça
toujours été le cas depuis des années et
donc c'est en quelque part en quelque
sorte l'annonce officielle si ça vient
de parking Palace c'est-à-dire que il y
a pas de doute à voir la reine est bien
décédée de la Maison Blanche nos pensées
vont à la famille au peuple du
Royaume-Uni également une réaction de
John majeur ancien Premier ministre qui
lui aussi donc salut cette cette reine
et ses 70 ans de règne Agnès Poirier
parce qu'on parle effectivement du
prince Charles qui devient donc le tout
nouveau monarque aujourd'hui le roi
Charles peut-être des modifications
qu'il va faire au sein de cette
monarchie sur les Philippines
cette annonce alors puis c'est la
première fois que ça arrive n'est pas
posté sur les grilles de Back impasse en
fait c'est possible château de balmorrow
là où la reine est décédée que vous
voyez derrière on voit donc ce sont
c'est une image en Écosse alors c'est le
château de malmorol que l'on voit
il y a quelques instants maintenant et
donc se communiquer de Buckingham Palace
mais en fait au château de Balmoral donc
Agnès Poirier oui peut-être qu'il va y
avoir des changements avec justement
Charles ce que disait à l'instant Jérémy
hustub en tout cas il y a ces 70 ans de
règne qui sont qui restent
exceptionnelles et c'est cela
aujourd'hui que
qui reste en fait de la reine Elizabeth
II
alors oui pas mais souvenez-vous aussi
que Victoria avait aussi régné très très
longtemps et finalement il y a il y a un
peu de Victoria chez la reine Elizabeth
et il y a ce sens du devoir parce que
Jérémy parler de à la fois l'empathie
mais qu'elle a eu depuis je dirais
seulement depuis la mort de la princesse
Diana puisque Tony Blair lui avait rendu
un énorme service en lui disant écoutez
là il va falloir nous sommes dans une
autre ère l'émotion et il faut que vous
montriez vos votre émotion à votre
peuple ce qu'elle avait réussi à faire
et depuis elle avait réussi à montrer
cette empathie
et donc
ce qu'on regardera d'elle c'est ce sens
du devoir chevillé au corps cette
constance effectivement et puis il a
longévité alors c'est une peut-être de
ses plus grandes qualités finalement
alors on j'ai dit que qu'est-ce qui va
se passer tout de suite
l'istre la première ministre va faire
une un discours vas s'adresser à la
nation
devant darn Street et ensuite c'est le
roi Charles alors est-ce qu'il va
prendre d'ailleurs question intéressante
est-ce qu'il va prendre le nom de
Charles à ce moment-là ce sera le roi
Charles III
où va-t-il prendre le nom ce qu'il peut
faire apprendre un de ses prénoms comme
Georges par exemple qui est le nom de
son grand-père va-t-il être roi Georges
on ne saurait très vite et ensuite donc
après les strass et bien c'est le roi
Charles
qui va s'adresser à la nation et ça
normalement c'était d'après le protocole
décidé depuis plusieurs années c'est à
18h le jour de la de la mort du
souverain mais comme en Grande-Bretagne
18h48 ce sera peut-être soit plus tard
soit demain Philippe c'est important ce
choix du nom du roi Charles
qu'est-ce que ça signifie
le champ le premier a été exécuté les
deux fleurs Richard de est un roi qui
pas très bien vu dans les yeux des
Britanniques donc peut-être pour Charles
il aura envie de changer de nom pour
pour devenir pour pas être connu sous un
autre nom de roi je personnellement je
pense qu'il va regarder son prénom parce
qu'on a toujours connu comme chien quand
le prince Charles etc donc ça sera quand
même bizarre après toutes ces années
d'attentes de
tout d'un coup
avoir un roi qui est Charles mais qui ne
s'appelle plus Charles s'il avait
peut-être 25 ans ou 30 ans où il était
beaucoup plus jeune que il changera non
mais
a priori il va rester sur WhatsApp mais
par contre ce qui est important à savoir
c'est que il y a beaucoup de questions
qui étaient posées depuis longtemps saut
est-ce que c'est chiant qui va succéder
à sa mère ou est-ce que ça va être
directement passé à William et si oui
comment ça peut se passer ça se fait pas
comme ça c'est-à-dire que il y a une
lignée de succession donc après la reine
c'est son fils aîné donc chant qui lui
succède ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui
personne peut le pousse à la porte c'est
pas le gouvernement c'est pas le premier
ministre il y a deux façons de me faire
la première c'est que il décide qui n'a
pas envie de le faire on verra bien ou
il meurt avant sa mère donc ça c'est pas
le cas donc c'est normal que je suis en
trois rois quoi qu'il en soit maintenant
qu'il est waouh il va pas être roi
pendant des décennies comme sa mère il
est déjà un monsieur d'un certain âge il
a 74 ans cette année donc il n'a pas 70
ans de règne devant lui la la la je
pense que on voit on va une reine de 10
15 20 au maximum et quand on compare la
situation actuelle il y a un précédent
qui de la reine Victoria qui a régné de
1837 à 1901
et son fils lui a succédé edwa 7 et elle
doit être à régner pour montrer peu de
temps neuf ans mais il a quand même
marqué son époque avec énormément de
changement dans un monde archives dans
la société britannique il se peut que je
suis Enrique et envie de faire
exactement la même chose donc dans un
temps plus court Jérémy stop c'est à
dire que le roi Charles pourrait faire
des modifications au sein de cette
monarchie c'est fort probable une
opportunité peut-être pour lui est-ce
que c'est un désir il sait toujours
présenté comme quelqu'un qui modernise
et il a besoin de quitter l'ombre de sa
mère donc il va essayer quand même de
garder un sens de la tradition parce
qu'il sait que sa mère a été très
populaire donc il ne va pas
en quelque sorte
s'affranchir de ça mais en même temps il
veut exister enfin en et pour lui-même
donc il va faire des choses d'une
manière différente c'est certain
le 4 juin 1953 en fait quelques mois
après qu'elle soit arrivée qu'elle a
accéder au trône puisque c'était en 1952
Elizabeth II c'est à prononcé ces
quelques mots que je voudrais vous faire
écouter
je déclare devant vous tous que je
consacrerai toute ma vie qu'elle soit
longue ou courte
à votre service et au service de la
grande famille impériale à laquelle nous
appartenons
c'est 1948 me dit Philippe Turl et
effectivement
47 l'avait elle avait fait ce discours
pour dire que sa vie soit longue ou
courte et ça toujours ou service du
Dijon et du peuple
britannique c'est ce qui reste tout de
même d'Elizabeth II Jeremy stop non ce
qu'elle vient de dire là parce qu'on se
discours de 1900 donc 47 oui c'est une
vie de de service et en quelque sorte
c'est curieux parce que le prince
Charles en tant que Prince de Galles à
la devise ectine je sers mais jusqu'à
présent c'est vraiment ça sa mère qui a
été
exemplaire à cet égard et lui il aura du
mal à mon avis à l'égalité
devant Buckingham Palace ce sont des
images en direct tous ces britanniques
qui veulent rendre hommage
la reine à la reine Elizabeth II je ne
sais pas si vous voyez ces images Agnès
Poirier vous qui êtes à Londres mais
c'est vrai que ça commence à être
impressionnant cet hommage global ce qui
va rester véritablement ce sont ses 70
ans de règne
oui alors en fait ce qui va rester mais
ce que nous avons perdu quand même c'est
un lien le lien vivant avec
la guerre et avec le la reconstruction
d'après-guerre et avec le consensus
et
le consensus d'après-guerre comme on le
dit en Bretagne et qui est formidable
voilà et qui est formidable aujourd'hui
et donc peut-être que ça va rendre ce
monde là ou du moins l'héritage que nous
avons de la Concorde d'après-guerre plus
vulnérable encore Emmanuel Macron en
tout cas hommage sur Twitter à l'arrêt
Elizabeth II une amie de la France se
dit-il les hommages se multiplient le
Premier ministre irlandais donc il parle
également d'une amie et puis John Major
je vous le disais l'ancien Premier
ministre britannique qui lui rend
hommage le Premier ministre italien
également donc qui parle justement de
cet esprit de service qui avait
justement la reine Elizabeth II dont on
vient de parler Kevin Guyot c'est ça que
vous retiendrez vous de la reine
Elizabeth II cet esprit de service
qu'elle a eu pendant 70 ans de règne
je pense elle a vraiment des 8 toute sa
vie au Royaume-Uni rendez vous compte
elle est devenue reine avec 26 ans à 26
ans on est extrêmement jeune on n'a pas
forcément comme ambition de devenir
rénovaire et ce qu'elle voulait à la
base à ce moment à cette époque là
c'était vers sa vie en tant que femme
d'officine parce que le principe était
un officier de marine à ce moment-là
elle avait deux enfants et ce qu'elle
voulait c'était s'occuper de sa peine et
finalement la santé sous hyper à
rattrapie sa santé et donc elle a
rencontré sa vie par nous expliquer que
du coup elle a dû monter sur le trône
à nouveau parce qu'on vous entend on
vous entend très mal le Premier ministre
indien
qui
n'arrêtera maudit donc inquiet en fait
peiné il le dit par la mort de la reine
Philippe Turl il faut parler de ces pays
du commonwealt d'ailleurs fait partie
des pays fondateurs des des
pays du Commonwealth est-ce que ça va
changer les choses parce qu'en fait
c'était compliqué de faire en sorte que
ces pays restent au sein cette
communauté je vous dis on rentre dans un
dans un dans une nouvelle ère et une
nouvelle période pour le commandement
parce que la reine est ont été reine
pendant 70 ans elle a vu le
démantèlement de l'empire britannique et
en train de démontrer quand elle est
devenue renommée 1952 mais la à la vue
la fin de l'Empire britannique et la
création du communois depuis 1961 il y
en a 56 pays qui sont membres
aujourd'hui
je pense que
alors que la reine reste chef d'Etat
d'une partie de ces pays ces il me
semble il va y avoir certains pays qui
vont demander maintenant à couper le
cordon
d'abord à l'Australie à la
Nouvelle-Zélande au Canada et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui à cause de ce lien avec
ce personnage historique depuis
tellement longtemps ces pays-là ont dit
nous resterons avec et les abeilles
comme chef d'État mais le jour où elle
disparaît là on va faire le nécessaire
pour couper le cordon et donc je pense
qu'on peut voir maintenant à Mathon
avoir que certains pays vont dire nous
voulons plus que la famille wall
britannique soit notre chef d'État
d'accord donc il y a un risque tout de
même que ça tangue un peu du côté de
tous ces pays du commonwei
en ce qui concerne le commonwear ce qui
est probable c'est que les paiements
décident désormais délire un des leurs
comme en quelque sorte chef à la place
du monarque britannique
ce ne sera pas exactement une sorte de
révolte mais ce sera et on peut dire une
forte République qui nous ation en
quelque sorte du commonwef est-ce que ça
risque de changer également Philippe
unité du Royaume-Uni par qu'on sait que
l'Écosse a peut-être des velléités
d'indépendance est-ce que la reine
Elizabeth II avait vraiment jouer ce
rôle et aujourd'hui il va y avoir une
sorte de fragilité plus forte ou pas oui
non je pense que évidemment la mort
d'Eliza va être de ne va pas aider les
choses dans ton sens mais vous savez
même si l'Écosse avait demandé
l'indépendance et avec gagner le
référendum sans indépendance et même si
un autre référendum que l'école je ne la
première ministre écossaise aimerait
bien
organiser
le Charles restera toujours roi d'Écosse
et roi de d'Angleterre mais c'est vrai
que je pense pour Elizabeth ça aurait
été un grand chagrin de voir le pays
Royaume-Uni se dispersaient entre
plusieurs pays dont c'est quelque chose
au moins qu'elle ne verra pas qu'elle ne
verra pas mais donc vous ne l'excluez
pas c'est Philippe possible et c'est pas
demain la veille Agnès Poirier sur cette
fragilité justement de l'unité du
Royaume-Uni
ben on va sans doute connaître c'est les
prochaines heures et les prochains jours
un soubresaut de l'unionisme et avant
sans doute la fin de cette union en fait
qui a été vraiment mis à mal par le
brexit et la reine c'était un petit peu
comme d'autres institutions comme
l'armée comme la BBC mais la BBC aussi
est mise à mal le ciment de ces quatre
nations qui composent le Royaume-Uni et
ma foi nous avons arrêté la dame même si
les consultatifs prévus dans un an des 5
octobre 2024 en Écosse si l'Écosse
obtient peut-être la valve la validation
de Westminster pour ce
référendum si
il est positif pour l'indépendance et
bien que peut-être la réunification de
l'Irlande est à envisagée
elle est certainement envisagée les
sondages montrent que le sentiment
entre enfin sentiment favorable à cette
réunification existe même si elle n'est
pas encore majoritaire donc oui c'est la
fin du nerf Philippe a tout à fait
raison c'est la fin du maire et mais
pour le moment ces prochaines heures ces
prochains jours ses premières semaines
en tout cas
jusqu'à la fin du protocole et de la de
la disparition de toute la pompe autour
de la disparition de de la reine et bien
vous pouvez vous attendre au contraire
espèce de l'Union l'union sacrée mais
qui ne durera pas
sacrée en tout cas pour les quelques
jours qui vont venir puisque le
Royaume-Uni est en deuil et ça va être
un deuil national et ça va durer
plusieurs jours c'est ce que nous
expliquait Philippe
émotion peut-être encore plus que pour
la princesse Diana c'est avoir mais ce
qui est certain pour l'instant c'est que
la reine est morte mais pas la monarchie
la monarchie continue et ce serait un
peu hâtif de vouloir y mettre fin déjà
nous verrons ce que nous verrons dans
les années à venir il a l'air beaucoup
d'émulsions Philippe
que nous avons toujours connu qu'on a
comme vraiment considéré un peu comme
dans le deuxième maman quelque part
parce qu'elle a toujours été présent et
il monte a complètement changé depuis
1952 en sortie de la guerre il y avait
encore de la rationnement on l'a vu elle
arrive la télévision la télévision
couleur un homme qui marche sur la lune
les réseaux sociaux le mariage gay tout
ça s'est passé pendant la reine
Elizabeth
c'est un personnage énorme qui ne quitte
aujourd'hui donc il faut tout
reconstruire mais la monarchie il est
vrai continue j'ai confiance en
printemps pour relever le défi ça fait
quand même 70 ans qu'il attend ce jour
donc s'il arrive pas à faire quelque
chose de bien et bien ça m'étonnerait
donc c'est vrai que va y avoir il va y
avoir beaucoup d'émotions parce que
c'est un personnage tellement hors norme
tellement énorme que ça ne pourrait pas
être autrement merci beaucoup en tout
cas c'est effectivement une époque la
fin d'une époque et donc le Royaume-Uni
en deuil puisque donc la reine Elizabeth
est décédée à 96 ans donc après 70 ans
de règne merci beaucoup Philippe
Philippe Tower le merci Jérémy stop
merci Agnès Poirier merci Kevin Guyot et
puis merci bien sûr à Hervé Hervé Amoric
et toujours notre correspondant à
Londres on va revenir en images pour
terminer justement ce débat sur les 70
ans de règne de la reine Elizabeth donc
en images
pour célébrer ces 90 ans elle arborait
comme à son habitude une tenue et un
chapeau aux couleurs assorties une image
reconnaissable entre toutes et devenue
iconique
né en 1926 elle n'était pourtant pas
destinée à devenir souveraine mais
disons plus tard quand son oncle Édouard
huit renonce au trône par amour c'est le
père d'Elizabeth George VI qui devient
roi
conductrice d'ambulance pour l'armée
britannique pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale Elisabeth assume pleinement son
rôle de princesse héritière
[Musique]
et sa vie fut longue le plus long règne
de l'histoire de la monarchie
britannique
[Musique]
le 9 septembre 2015 Élisabeth balle
record établit par sa trisailleule la
reine Victoria
la mort subite de son père en 1952 place
Elisabeth sur le trône elle n'a alors
que 25 ans son couronnement est suivi
par plus de 20 millions de personnes
[Musique]
osacre succède alors des temps
bouleversés pour la reine l'Empire
britannique se meurt les unes après les
autres les anciennes colonies prennent
leur indépendance c'est le temps du
Commonwealth
au Royaume-Uni c'est l'époque des
swinging sixties et de la remise en
cause de la monarchie
les enfants d'Elizabeth après des
histoires de conte de fées divorce les
uns après les autres et voilà le clan
royal qui va s'y
en 1997 c'est une tragédie qui ébranle
la couronne la mort de la princesse
Diana plonge le royaume dans un deuil
immense la reine elle se mur dans le
silence une réaction qui affecte
profondément ces sujets
Elisabeth mettra une semaine avant
d'ordonner la mise en berne des drapeaux
celle qui a pour devises de ne jamais se
justifier ni se plaindre devra
s'expliquer à la télévision
[Musique]
mais avec le temps la reine retrouve sa
popularité les mariages princiers Kate
et William Meghan et Harry et les
naissances des arrières petits enfants
redonne des couleurs à une monarchie
vieillissante
en 2012 le jubilé qui consacre ses 60
ans de règne et suivi par des dizaines
de milliers de personnes et Elisabeth II
a toujours refusé d'appliquer elle
gardera dans la mémoire de ses sujets
l'image d'une femme de caractère qui a
voulu toute sa vie préservée la royauté
[Musique]